ce blindé ukrainien avance rapidement
sur ce champ de bataille aux abords de
barmouth car il y a quelques jours à
peine les Russes occupaient ce
territoire ces soldats Ukrainiens
déambule sur les quelques kilomètres qui
ont été reconquis selon
pierreformations quand on regarde
l'ampleur de notre avancée et le nombre
de victimes russes c'est impressionnant
à quelques kilomètres de la ligne de
front ces soldats se reposent dans ce
bunker souterrain il reste vigilant la
Russie contre toujours la quasi-totalité
de barmut les récents gains territoriaux
leur apportent de l'espoir mardi Kiev a
revendiquer la libération d'environ 20
km² au nord et au sud de la périphérie
de barthout
nous savons ce que nous faisons nous
savons comment nous devons attaquer
comment nous devons nous défendre nous
savons qu'au bout du compte dans deux
trois ou cinq ans je ne sais pas nous
gagnerons cette guerre sur ces images
reçues mardi le commandant des forces
terrestres ukrainiennes rend visite aux
soldats combattants dans la région et
les encourage
vous nous rapprochez de la victoire et
vous nous permettez de préparer les
autres soldats qui participeront à
l'offensive prochaine c'est pourquoi
nous sommes très reconnaissants
depuis des mois bien que la date de la
contre-offensive ukrainienne reste
incertaine ces troupes l'attendent avec
impatience
et les mys